el pitbull y el doctor alexander muestra
el lugar donde cayó una de las 13 bombas
que impactaron el hospital que dirige
tres más el otro son muestra reno cayó
en ese lado del hospital la otra en el
otro y una más en lo profundo del jardín
en el techo y otras más explotaron en
los alrededores
las autoridades ucranianas han
denunciado que desde el comienzo de la
guerra las fuerzas rusas han atacado
sistemáticamente hospitales
especialmente donde hay presencia de
niños este está en la población de
mykolaiv en el sur del país y fue
atacado el pasado 4 de abril y quedan
muestras de esos ataques en cada una de
estas ventanas y en la fachada del
edificio
ellos saben que esto es un hospital
infantil donde no hay militares
pero hay niños heridos leche
el fiscal general ucraniano asegura que
219 niños han muerto desde el comienzo
de la guerra y 404 han quedado heridos
el 98% de los niños que llegan a este
hospital lo hacen en condiciones de
extrema gravedad
los doctores dicen que al menos 30 niños
han llegado al hospital heridos por
ataques de las fuerzas rusas pero
también nos dicen que no solamente tiene
que ver con ataques específicos que la
guerra ha pasado a permear lo todo que
el estrés de la sociedad es bastante
grande por ejemplo este pequeño que está
aquí al lado está quemado su casa se
incendió viene de una familia numerosa y
los niños están tan estresados que
muchas veces hacen cosas inesperadas y
este otro joven que está a mis espaldas
y va en una moto muy rápido y se
accidentó
la vida no solamente ha cambiado para
los niños sino también para el personal
médico muchos de ellos viven
permanentemente en el hospital
no
[Música]
lo más difícil es cuando los niños
llegan heridos de muerte
nerviosa metros y no se les puede salvar
la vida tenía muchos fondos
para doctores como julia es difícil
manejar el dolor que se ha ido
acumulando con el paso de los días
singh